on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood uncensored tonight
the kiss that became a global Scandal
Spain's government says its football
boss represents the very worst of
society Luis rubialis insists he will
not quit was it just a moment of Madness
or is this a me too moment for football
we'll debate
the million dollar mug shot Trump's
jailbird snap was expected to humiliate
the former president and prove that
Justice applies to all but was it a gift
wrap boost to his campaign
plus 60 years ago Martin Luther King had
a dream how much of it has come true
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening welcome to
Pierce Morgan uncensored with me Rosanna
Lockwood in a chat for a final week for
Pierce still away now that kiss at the
Women's World Cup is a story that's not
going away is it in fact it's only
getting stranger today the mother of
Luis rubialis announced she's locked
herself in a church in Spain and is on a
hunger strike in protest against what
she's calling the inhuman hunt against
her son and I no doubt it's been
stressful for her and rubialis and their
whole family watching his reputation
disintegrate the mob justice of social
media and news is an overwhelming thing
to experience but I'm afraid that's
where my sympathy ends because the
responsibility of all of this lies at
Ruby Alice's own fate not only for the
stupid kiss itself but the way he and
the Spanish or Federation have handled
everything since he is the enemy that
he's looking for in all of this and if
he had a shred of self-awareness or
humility he would realize that the
president of Spain's top women's league
actually put it best when she said quote
his ego is greater than his dignity and
honor I mean to be quite Frank a
gentleman acknowledges when he's wrong
an apology an acknowledgment if it had
done adequately it might have been an
embarrassing admission of failure for
him but the story would be over already
instead rubialis is doubling down
[Applause]
it was a kiss a spontaneous kiss I know
that there's a still picture with both
my hands paralyzed but I'm going to
recount the complete sequence now it was
spontaneous
euphoric and consented which is
do you think I have to resign
foreign
[Music]
well all of this is now completely
overshadowing Spain's Amazing World Cup
win and that's something else rubialis
should be really ashamed of and a
reminder there is a reason this is all
being described as Spain's metoo moment
it's not just a fight about a kiss it's
a fight about being listened to when a
woman says she didn't consent to
something believe her
joining me to discuss all this is
Spanish football journalist semra Hunter
and in the studio we've got socialist
author Grace Blakely and talk TV's
Esther kraku all three of you thank you
for rejoining me we actually discussed
all this with you last Thursday and
summer so much
has happened since then are you shocked
by the developments that have taken
place
yes
I really am it just is getting crazier
Wilder
um stranger more Bizarre by the moment
by the day and yes there is so much
that's been unfolding over the last few
days since we spoke
um obviously FIFA has suspended Luis
obelis provisionally for 90 days he is
not to do anything related to football
in any way shape or form as it relates
to a national International level he is
not allowed to have any contact with
Jenny hermoso of any kind either
directly or through a third party that
goes for the Federation as well we have
since heard from Jorge vilda and putting
out a statement that was quite honestly
not the most sincere I would say
considering that he's such a fervent
supportive Luis rubiales made no mention
of Jenny hermoso whatsoever of any kind
and his whole coaching staff just about
walked out as well on Saturday beyond
that there were six or seven members who
also resigned after that incredible
speech on Friday it has since come to
light that the whole reason why luizio
Reales try to make everyone believe that
he was going to stand down was because
you need to have a call you need to have
a 50 attendance rate in order for a
meeting to happen and because so many
people were dropping up they didn't want
to go
he's basically lured them into going by
saying he was stepping down so there
were a lot of incredulous people in the
audience as well because they did not
expect to hear what they heard on top of
that today
um the criminal court has opened up
proceedings against him because as we
mentioned I think on Thursday because of
that law which is called on the yeses
yes which has to do with consent if
there is no consent then it is
considered a crime so there have been
four official complaints that went
through to the courts of the
prosecutor's office in Madrid they took
it to the National court and now they
are going to look at this as a potential
criminal case and as an alleged or a
potential Act of sexual aggression so
he's got it coming out in from all
different angles right now and right now
the Federation is also still undergoing
their emergency meeting which started at
four o'clock this afternoon where
they're debating what to do about all of
this mess on top of that this General
Secretary asked UEFA to suspend the
Spanish Federation as a way of trying to
threaten the Spanish government and if
they were to do so then no Spanish club
could feature in any European
competition it's just insane and you
already mentioned his mother yeah his
mother I mean come on somewhere because
I mean yeah the bureaucratic
administrative side of it is astonishing
and so many different sites challenging
each other saying we're not going to
play for you anymore you're not going to
be allowed in this Association we're
going to file proceedings but the mother
at the center of this all I mean surely
his biggest Defender
[Laughter]
and now apparently she even has a
support group of about 100 people who
have turned up to I guess cheer her on
or make her feel better or or just
support her
um because obviously I mean as a mother
she's going through a very difficult
moment even though it is a bit of an
extreme way to try and handle the
situation but I suppose she is under
extreme amount of duress at the moment
because her son is quite literally
Public Enemy Number One
let's bring in our studio guest Esther
and Grace I see you had chimed in there
on the mother got another point
you know a group of African mothers on
WhatsApp I I have figured it out I have
figured out what went wrong with this
whole thing yeah so in the beginning I
said let's not be angry on her behalf
because that statement that was released
by the Spanish um Football Association
said that she was defending him and that
they had a close relation of all that
and then it came out that she was
actually pressured or something that
wasn't genuinely a statement from her
which made me think okay many people
need firing because you can't put out a
statement in someone's name without
their explicit consent so I didn't
understand what was going on there and
then he he gives this odd speech where
he said I'm not resigning look at the
end of the day if he had genuinely said
if she felt uncomfortable I'm sorry and
it was just in the heat at the moment we
would have all forgotten about it and it
would have gone away because at the end
of the day I think it's twofold of
course you can't do things with these
with Without You can't touch someone or
kiss someone without their consent but
we said oh given the culture and the
Heat of the Moment and she apparently
based on that statement didn't have
problem with it it's fine it's just
something that Spanish people do Spain
is the kissing capital of the world now
we realize she didn't want it to happen
his mother's going on Hunger Strike I
mean it's great I think what's happened
here is that um an individual has become
a lightning rod for a wider basically
what's become a big culture War issue
right so yes if he just you know stood
back and said I apologize
exactly I unreservedly apologize and you
know that could have been dealt with
between the two of them it had been
dealt with by the team Etc but because
he didn't say that it then went into the
media and suddenly everyone had to pick
a side as they always do in the cultural
War battles
um and Spain has this massive issue with
the far right um often you know who are
linked to what was a very extremely
right-wing authoritarian regime in Spain
that was only um removed in like the the
70s
um and the far right are doing very well
on the back of you know the classic
lines about like feminism gone mad and
political correctness gone mad and
there's all this stuff that's wrong with
Society because of women because they're
not taking up their traditional roles so
now this is the perfect issue to
actually divide people and say oh look
at this poor man who's being um you know
called over the coals for something very
natural look at his poor mother versus
everyone else who's like yes it's
obviously insane and something else this
didn't need to become a cultural issue
because because
we cannot we can understand like look at
football when people are smacking each
other on the bum we could understand
this is something that happened in the
heat at the moment but we also have to
draw a hard boundary saying if this
person didn't like it just say I'm sorry
have respect and we can move on but
that's not what's happening and that's
why this whole Madness that's what gets
lost when we get into this cultural
stuff isn't it because you just it
becomes impossible to build Bridges
across sides saying this individual
person made a mistake but it is
connected to these wider patterns of you
know misogyny or like sexism that we see
let's let them make a mistake and then
change things and and try and move
forward it's look let's bring in our
resident Spaniard on this camera you
were listening in on that and um I
believe some people are actually
beginning to march in Madrid this
evening I've seen videos with that sort
of I don't know how many but a few sort
of in support could this really uh be a
metoo movement for Spain is it fair what
we're saying about it being a culture
War issue for you guys now
it is very much a point of contention
but I wouldn't say that it's dividing
Society it's quite the opposite I've
never seen anything like it in Spain
it's extraordinary it's actually United
Society so many people overwhelming
numbers of people have been supporting
Jenny hermoso have been showing her
massive amounts of support whether it's
on the streets I've been protests going
on for days now whether it's on social
media whether it's government officials
coming out to speak about it whether
it's the 81 members of the Spanish
national team both past and present the
23 World Cup winners and previous
national team players who signed a
document saying we're not going to
represent Spain and for called up until
leadership is removed then you have also
male footballers not many but some have
come out to show their support as well
clubs football organizations within the
industry everyone has come out and
spoken on behalf of General mosso in
support no one really has come out to
show any kind of public support to
rubianes of any kind and I think part of
it has to do with going back to this
cultural Point uh that you you bring up
for many this was the the straw that
broke the camel's back this case was
just the tip of the iceberg and going
back to some of the other things you
touched on it really was just a prime
example of the systemic
um abuse that has been going on within
the Federation and within the Women's
National Team for the better part of a
decade now and these women have been
speaking about this for an incredibly
long time about how they used to feel
scared they didn't feel safe that they
could go to the work environment they
were ridiculed they were humiliated they
were silenced they were controlled they
were manipulated and it is systemic
within the organization very quickly
asked the question I just I just very
quickly want to ask a question before we
have to leave I just want to know what
the the far-right parties like Vox for
example or what that whole movement has
to say about this if there is some
divide there as well or is this
literally even you know the extreme
writer saying actually this is fine
to be honest with you I actually haven't
really seen anything from the extreme
right about this and also in general the
extreme right has lost a bit of momentum
here in Spain they lost I think about 14
seats in the recent elections so people
are not necessarily supporting them as
much as they used to and so it would be
interesting to hear what they have to
say
um obviously I don't want to say that
they haven't entirely because maybe
someone has I just haven't seen it but
by and large again it's been just an
incredible amount of people who have
United on this front and people who
actually men including uh for as an
example there were men in the media who
initially supported Luis and then
realized once people started talking
about this they decided to listen to
learn and they said actually you know
what we're really sorry we made a
mistake but you see here I I disagree on
on one point because I think it's
important to not conflate two different
issues right I understand the the issue
of sexual harassment that women face in
various professions and all of that but
the reality is we have to contextualize
it because this man did this in front of
millions of people he couldn't have done
it in a more public way and he kissed
multiple players so I think for people
that assume that actually you know and
given men's sports we see them smacking
each other on the bombs and they hug and
they kiss and all of that I think it was
it's not a sign that someone is a
misogynist for instance or someone like
me to assume actually maybe there's a
cultural you know element here and this
isn't the Heat of the Moment and all of
that I don't think we should conflate
that with the very real issues
we completely agreed there but I think
for people that actually defended him in
the beginning and said actually he
kissed multiple players this is in front
of everyone you don't commit sexual
assault in front of millions of people
on camera it's not something really that
happens I think to conflate that or to
say people that sort had that view in
the beginning with people that just
don't get it or that are misogynist I
think that's unfair how it's played out
clearly it's under they're clearly
bigger underlying issues but that's what
that was the point I made at the very
beginning go on that I did
the reason why people feel is that this
is enacting the surgery on his heart is
that this is not a one-off incident for
example there is a very real case of a
woman who filed a police report for
physical assaults once upon a time there
was another woman to Mara Ramos who
opened this one was he convicted was he
convicted
no in the end he wasn't but I'm just
saying that it was brought forward he
did code
the reality
it doesn't matter but what I am saying
sometimes even if convicted or not these
things do happen we know even if it's
not so difficulties
all I'm saying is that there have been
plenty of allegations throughout the
years and women coming forward filing
police reports filing reports to the
higher courts to have this investigated
to have this looked at they have also
brought forward evidence for whatever
reason it wasn't necessarily
investigated maybe one day it will be
but there have been plenty of cases
where women have come forward and said
listen I had been on the receiving end
of misogynistic and sexist abuse by this
man tomorrow is a perfect example she
spoke to the meeting the other day she
said he humiliated me on a regular basis
he used to ask me what color my
underwear is in front of big names
within the the football men's Community
she used to say to her did you just come
here to get down on your knees so I mean
there are examples of History here yeah
it's not like it just happened in this
burn moment it was a one-off there is
very much a past that context is really
important of course we've got to say you
know that those were some of those are
allegations those people on here
obviously to defend themselves you know
Etc but it's really important to hear
the context we appreciate you giving the
history of that as well Grace and Esther
thank you for your inputs on this as
well I never thought we'd talk so much
about women's football on this show but
here we are Sam regards Nest thanks so
much
next tonight the million dollar mug shot
Trump's jailbird snap was expected to
humiliate the former president and prove
that Justice applies to all but was it a
gift wrapped boost for his campaign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
talk TV's very own Piers Morgan
uncensored is nominated in the brand new
TV interview category at this year's
National Television Awards best TV
interview of course he's up for it it's
probably all those exclusive interviews
with the likes of Cristiano Ronaldo
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed Donald Trump I believe it
was a free and fair election then you're
a fool Kanye West I'm simply going to
challenge you interview adjourned have I
forgotten anyone wake up people I mean
he does get some good interviews it has
to be said prime minister Mr President
first lady Stormy Daniels they have all
been fantastic interviews and if you
agree yeah you can vote for peers go
online have your say
nationaltvawards.com
like scan that code vote for peers
please get behind him and vote we know
we're new we know we're different the
force behind talk deserves to win keep
it award-winning Piers Morgan uncensored
vote for him so get online and cast your
vote for peers now give the poor guy a
chance please I beg you good luck Fizz
good luck bears let it roll
[Music]
and there's that reminder that you can
vote for Piers Morgan unscented in the
best TV interview category at the
National Television Awards go online
have your say a nationaltvawards.com or
by using your phone to scan this QR code
on your screen just now
do vote for Piercy would love it now
welcome back to on sense of me Rosanna
local to the info appears just for the
next few days then he's back from his
holes and I know one story he's been
following very closely Trump
get more trials more criminal procedures
more everything else and of course we
had that mug shot seen around the world
days since former president Donald Trump
was booked and charged inside an Atlanta
jail house this picture of him has
become a money spinner would you believe
it for his presidential campaign more
than seven million dollars has been
raised by his team that's what they're
saying anyway they're selling T-shirts
beer glasses bumper stickers domed with
a scaled face of the Don the Republican
front runner so who is the real mug here
the man packed by the police or the
scores of people who've paid for their
own piece of it well to discuss that I'm
joined by billionaire investor Kevin
O'Leary and by the founder and CEO of
the Investment Company Point bridge
Capital Hal Lambert also a major
Republican donor who switched his
support from Trump to Ron DeSantis so
gentlemen thanks for making time for us
this evening Kevin I'll I'll start with
you I mean there really was no other way
Trump was going to spin this other than
the money raising opportunity right
well these are in precedented times
we've never had a situation in a
presidential election where over 90
indictments have been basically
registered and the trouble is probably
if if you're an anti-trumper I mean you
have to look at it from both sides of
the aisle it's the fair way to review
this situation uh it's so noisy now that
no one remembers one indictment from
another so if another 100 indictment
comes it's just background noise
regarding how it's moving the needle
that's the problem for both sides it
isn't it doesn't seem to matter the
first election with Republican parties
come and gone everybody's still at one
percent except the scientists he hasn't
moved the needle either either and Trump
Remains the far ahead Forerunner and
these these indictments have not had any
traction so to actually monetize it
looks like a brilliant marketing move
that that shot that mug shot if you hate
Trump you want to wear it proudly if you
love Trump you want to wear it wear it
proudly and that's what they're doing
and and it it appeals it seems on the
merchandising front to both sides and
that's remarkable it really is and so
they're doing a lot of fundraising at
the five to twenty dollar level online
it's been highly motivational for the
Trump base and it really boils down at
the end of the day to what happens in
just a few States as it always does in a
presidential election it'll be
Pennsylvania probably that decides by
less than a hundred thousand votes what
do those independent voters think that's
unknown
like as you said both sides they are
really important to bear in mind uh on
this although in the UK we have a
product called Marmite which people say
you love to hate and I think when you're
looking at the the anti-trumpers as you
called them there they may even be a
money spinning opportunity here I mean
look there are some memes our producers
have prepared about this uh let's take a
look uh he got him as the Joker here uh
in a National Portrait Gallery or
something like that I mean you know this
type of stuff seems to fare well for him
and it's stuff that he's used to Hal
talking about the money side of it
um Trump is in need of quite a lot of
money I'm not talking about his personal
uh finances we've also obviously seen
bits of tax receipts and things over the
years but in terms of his legal fees
astonishing at this point
yeah I mean he it was reported he spent
over 40 million dollars just in the
first half of this year of some legal
experts I've spoken to estimate it's
going to cost him over 10 million
dollars a month going forward uh that's
a lot of money and so he's trying to you
know raise this small dollar money to
pay those legal costs so you've got
people making forty fifty thousand
dollars a year effectively subsidizing a
multi-billionaire's legal fees uh you
know it's their choice to do but uh you
know it's not being spent to get him
reelected I mean he's going to be
spending most of his money on on legal
fees and most of his time so I think
that's going to be a a real detriment to
him uh he gets all the the free media
that's that's helpful and that's what's
kept his poll numbers up but as far as
being able to campaign and being able to
actually get out and get in these states
he's gonna I mean Imagine One indictment
he's got four uh it's it's going to be a
lot of stress a lot of pressure a lot of
time with you know obviously requests
from legal on on Discovery and all those
kinds of things it's expensive if it's
time consuming and I I think it's a real
disservice quite frankly uh to the to
the Republican party and and to donors
uh for much of that money to have to be
used that way uh versus being uh
re-electing uh people into Congress or a
president and I'll put you you mentioned
the four indictments there Kevin
mentioned the sort of scatter gun
Approach at the at the start when he was
talking to us do you think if it is this
sort of uh lawfare as people are saying
this strategy is going to succeed or
fail for the side that are trying to
stop him getting into the White House
hell
yeah I mean also foreign
with these indictments so so that's been
helpful will it last I mean we've got
another five months until the first uh
the first caucus there in Iowa and you
know the the Iowa caucus is very
different you've got to be there you've
got to be working the ground the same
thing with New Hampshire the same thing
with South Carolina so it's not a
national election so we're not to
Pennsylvania yet and by the way uh if we
look at polling you know The
Independents are not for Trump on this
so I don't even if we looked at
Pennsylvania right now I don't see Trump
winning that state that's the problem I
have with this whole thing is
independent you know over 53 percent of
the country thinks that Trump is guilty
so when you go into that with that
number um that assumes those people are
not going to vote for him that's that
seems like a losing hand going into the
election yeah and you know yeah Kevin
you were mentioning the problem is
Emerson pulling out latest uh this is
after these Republican debates which of
course Trump didn't take parties about
Tucker Carlson instead but he was down
six percentage points DeSantis up two
potential points but Trump's still way
way out ahead and Kevin what about this
point the Hal brings up you know people
are entitled to buy a beer mug or a
bumper sticking with Trump's face on it
but they're funding his legal fees and
they may not be millionaires themselves
is there an Ethics point in that
I think there's a lot of ethical issues
but that doesn't determine who becomes
president great politicians great
leaders great generals great preachers
great managers are storytellers and at
the end of the day go back to Napoleon
he used to sit around the campfire with
his men and tell stories and those
stories emulate it all around the Empire
over a few months today that happens in
a few seconds on social media nothing is
more painful to watch than a boring
politician Trump is not boring now you
may find it just outrageous that a
potential president has been indicted
multiple times but there are millions of
people who simply don't care and at the
end of the day it's one vote at a time
now if they did care these polls at this
point should have moved on the first set
of indictments we're past 91 charges
nobody seems to care there now you know
it may frustrate people that don't like
Trump and it must frustrate people to do
but at the end of the day as I started
talking about this it's totally
unprecedented what happens next nobody
knows I will remind everybody that you
cannot become the president and pardon
yourself for a state charge you can do
that federally so this idea that he's
going to win the presidency and then
pardon himself that's not going to work
some of these charges like George are
state-based however also unprecedented
would be throwing a president or a
former president or an acting president
into prison that's not good for the
American brand many people speculate
even if he doesn't win the presidency
they won't put him in prison because
what does that say about America so all
of these narratives are happening at the
same time all of them unprecedented and
at the center of it a masterful genius
Storyteller that sucks the oxygen out of
all of his competitors and people keep
saying don't worry that'll change not so
far well if he doesn't get uh put in
prison what does it say about the
American justice system I guess would be
the cancer argument to that but here you
put on the storytelling how just finally
before we wrap up um one of these
criminal trials now set for next year
early 2024 the day uh before super
Tuesday what kind of effect is that
going to have
yeah I think it's going to have a
negative effect and I mean we're going
to possibly see Witnesses turn against
President former president Trump uh
they've indicted a lot of people so
we'll see what happens there but you
know you talk about being a great
Storyteller you know uh what happened to
Napoleon in the end you know you brought
up Napoleon he didn't turn out too well
at the end but I will say that maybe the
country's ready for more than a
Storyteller I mean look at DeSantis he's
there in Florida he's working around the
hurricane that's coming in he's looking
more presidential he's not having to
fight indictments I think there's
there's possible candidates out there
like Governor DeSantis that can show
leadership between now and the first
caucuses uh and people may change their
votes because the majority of the
country does care uh maybe the majority
of the Republican primary voters don't
care right now but the majority of the
country does and we're trying to win a
general election uh not 50 of the
Republican vote so you're back in
DeSantis now Hal Uh Kevin Hal thank you
so much great talking to you both
uncensored next tonight with Wagner
Varsity of guinea pig ocean out of the
picture what now for Putin and Russia's
credibility the future of its illegal
invasion of Ukraine I'll be joined by
former U.S ambassador to Nato Kurt
volcker he's in the studio next
foreign
[Music]
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever talk torture he may
have been going
somewhere is an excuse
for at what appears to be an abuse of
power when they first got together there
were press stories weighty Katie that
would make her a better princess of
wealth because you're not just marrying
the man you're marrying the job that
resonates with people Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air
thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to uncensored now the
former US ambassador to Nato Kurt
volcker described evgenie precautions
march on Moscow in June at the beginning
as the beginning of the end of Russia's
war on Ukraine well fast forward two
months navagna boss now confirmed by
Russian authorities to have died in that
plane crash last Wednesday the slow but
steady war in Ukraine of course rumbling
on
the Kremlin has denied killing pragosian
saying Western intelligence assessments
of Putin's and potential involvement are
an absolute quote lie so what now for
Russia Putin's credibility in the future
of its legal involvement in Ukraine
police say we're joined by the man
himself Kurt volcker former United
States ambassador to Nato and special
representative to Ukraine Kurt thank you
for making time for us and a busy time
for you I'm sure and
what do you make of those comments now
from two months ago when you said we
were going to begin to see the end we
saw that failed Mutiny on Moscow by the
Wagner troops now we see a dead
precaution the reason I said that and I
stand by it is that what we're seeing is
the bubble popping in Russia The
Narrative that Putin has been trying to
tell people about the war progosian took
on directly said it was a mistake to go
in said the war is going badly the
conditions for the soldiers are terrible
and he was marching on Moscow and he was
welcomed in rostov in boronage and then
negotiated an exit for time being but it
was clear that Russia was beginning to
turn on itself and that I think is what
we saw now just the other day with his
assassination as well that this is the
Russian State tearing itself apart or
the actors within it Putin burgosian
imagine shooting down an aircraft just
outside your capital city in order to
kill one of your Rivals there this is
not going well in Russia and it's
ultimately Russia's change that's going
to cause an end to the war in Ukraine
and it depends what sources you read how
overly optimistic you are that a
sentiment is changing in Russia
obviously they only get give
them by the state in terms of
information so very few people actually
believe Putin was behind the killing of
precaution which is stunning to us to
think about but it's very much the case
if you were asked if you're asked on the
street by somebody do you believe Putin
killed right what are you goodness what
are you going to say what are you going
to say absolutely now how do you think
this changes the way
um the situation plays out with Ukraine
but most notably uh calls for for NATO
to accept Ukraine or Ukraine to join
NATO you were you know a former
representative to Nato for the U.S your
position on it has been very clear
other people say it will just agitate
further well I don't think we have a
choice at this point I know we're not
quite there yet but Putin has declared
that Ukraine doesn't exist as a nation
of people and identity it's trying to
wipe out an entire European country and
he has explicitly said he's trying to
re-establish an Empire he's compared
himself to Catherine the Great into
Peter the Great an accumulator of
Russian lands so we're not going to have
NATO able to provide security for Europe
with Ukraine out of it because war will
continue so the only way to actually
lock down Europe again is to have a
clear hard line of deterrence so that
Russia doesn't attack anymore and that's
going to be with Ukrainian and all of
these countries and gray zones haven't
ultimately be in NATO now uh the voices
that were opposing to Ukraine joining
NATO and have been from the start also
the types of voices that you hear
opposing funding what we call the war in
Ukraine or sending more ammunition
weapons f-16s the type of that what
concern you about the upcoming U.S
election the way that that could change
things in terms of the voices that call
for ceding territory of Ukraine or
stopping sending weapons yeah it's it's
a tough one to say you know you have
former president Trump
um Vivek ramaswamy out there saying it's
terrible terrible we should stop
supporting Ukraine
um you have most of the other Republican
candidates and President Biden all
strongly in favor of supporting Ukraine
there's a clear majority in favor of
that even in the public there's a
majority in favor of that but it's going
to become a rancorous debate and what I
worry about most I guess to answer your
question is the White House needs to be
more assertive they need to explain the
U.S interest why it is in our interest
that Putin be stopped in Ukraine so that
we don't have to go elsewhere and then
to do everything possible to help
Ukraine win quickly we seem to be doling
this out you know one step at a time and
the ukrainians are paying the price and
it looks as though it is going slowly
and badly sometimes when in fact it
could be going better it's a
Communications exercise perhaps
partially
um one part of the current U.S Russia
relations that is interesting is there's
detention still of Evan gershkovic Wall
Street Journal journalist he's been
detained for last few months now uh very
limited hope of what's going to happen
for him at the moment and the only thing
you could guess at would be a prisoner
exchange of Russia but where this gets
complicated of course is some say that
if the U.S hadn't exchanged Brittany
Greiner who was detained a few months
ago for a war criminal at the time you
wouldn't now have this situation where
Evan was detained as well because Russia
sees as a bargaining chip well but we
still have Brittany Greiner in jail so I
mean Putin is going to take hostages and
then see what he can get for it and he
likes to take hostages that create some
kind of political pressure inside the
United States I think in the case of
Brittany Greiner it was one that was
really irritating to the Democratic base
which is therefore very annoying to
president who has to take care of them
so they really did as much as they could
to try to get her out and did it as you
said dubious exchange of a of a real
International arms trafficker and
criminal in the case of Evan gershowitz
it seems that they're trying to go for
someone who's connected more to the
right because I think they're trying to
increase the pressure of the right
particularly the far right against the
Biden Administration saying see what
you've done you're helping Ukraine and
now look at this you shouldn't be doing
that it's not playing that way but I
think that might be part of what the
Russians were trying to achieve it's sad
and cynical but that is that is case of
a lot of this detention strategy
has laid out as you said there um
in terms of where it could go from here
for gershkovic do you think there will
be some serious negotiations happening
do you think there is willing within the
by the administration to see him freed
well I'm sure there is I'm sure in the
Bible Administration that they are
sending out feelers what's the situation
here what can we do his lawyers are
going through the right motions of
filing the briefs that they're supposed
to file not that there's any operative
legal system in Russia but if you don't
do it they'll hold it against you that
you don't but I don't think Putin is
quite ready to trade yet and the reason
is because I think he knows he's losing
in Ukraine uh his forces have not been
able to take any new territory since
June and that was the Wagner Group which
has been off the playing field since
then
ukrainians are gradually taking back
territory in their counter-offensive
particularly in the South and if they're
able to break these logistical support
lines that get to Crimea it's going to
be really bad for Putin so I think he's
hanging on to Evan until he can see
where this is and and maybe longer even
still because he wants bargaining chips
at one other strand that might seem a
little bit obtuse to some viewers but is
Africa in all of this because the Wagner
group were incredibly active in the
continent there has even been
speculation that some forces from
African nations could be used within the
Ukraine you were creating War which is
astonishing to think of but with the
absence of precaution what is Russia's
influence over that continent now well I
think he's going to try to reconstitute
influence in Africa but under more
control
progosian became out of control out of
the Kremlin control anyway and they have
their own sources of income they were
doing their own thing in Ukraine they
started doing their own thing in Russia
and from Putin's perspective that's
enough so he shut them down but now I
think he still wants to have a mercenary
force with some degree of separation
from State organs that he can still
direct and do things in Africa so I
think they're going to try and put it
back it's a temporary setback but we'll
see where it goes absolutely look Kurt
volcker we appreciate you making time
for us coming to the studio here in
London good luck with the rest of your
travels thanks so much thank you well on
Stanford next tonight 60 years ago
Martin Luther King had a dream the March
on Washington paved the way for key
civil rights laws and changed the us
forever but how much of that dream has
been realized and is America now at risk
of heading in the opposite direction
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
coming up on the talk the home office
considers electronic tags for Asylum
Seekers police are ordered to
investigate every theft under new
government guidelines and prince Andrew
seems to be back in the Royal fold as
he's spotted in bowel mall but the rest
of the royal family that's all coming up
at nine
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored with me
Rosanna Lockwood now it was 60 years ago
today that over a quarter of a million
Americans descended onto the streets of
Washington DC to hear these words from
civil rights activist Dr Martin Luther
King
of a dream
that one day
this nation will rise up
live out the true meaning of its Creed
we hold these tools to be self-evident
that all men are created
now I've talked to King was to look at
today's America some say he might wonder
whether his dream has been realized just
this weekend police in Jacksonville
Florida said they believe the killing of
three black people by a 21 year old
white gunman was racially motivated the
incident has been condemned by all sides
including by the family of Dr King so
I'm pleased honored rather to say I'm
joined by Dr Martin Luther King's niece
alvida King and by Sharita Tate the
cousin of George Floyd and president of
the George Floyd Foundation thank you
ladies and here in the studio by talk TV
contributor Esther Krakow joining us
once again and author and playwright
Bonnie Greer well what a strong panel to
discuss this and Bonnie I will actually
start with you because you were just
sharing your um original memories from
Dr Martin Luther King's speech was
certainly an rdb on with all of you
expecting one of Dr King's relatives and
I have to say I was a young teenager
when this when this thing when they
March on Washington and they cleared the
channels it never happened before this
was a special so we came home from
school eating our milk and cookies and
then they said Dr King was going to be
on it and we've grown up watching Dr
King as little kids were going like okay
it was cool but okay and he was 16th
down on the the speakers Rostrum
this guy got up there we listened to the
speeches my uncle drove his truck there
we were all sitting there what they
don't tell you is that this speech was
impromptu he riffed this speech nobody
knew this was coming out of him he made
this up on the spot and you if you watch
his body you can see that was coming
through him if you saw it live you could
feel that this was like coming through
him I mean people were screaming and now
we sort of think of the speech as a kind
of iconic set piece it wasn't this was
off the cuff and that made it even more
exciting all from the heart all from the
heart alvida listening in on that
relative of Dr Martin Luther King he
must be used to hearing those types of
accounts now of what it meant to people
but do you think the words that he spoke
that day have been realized
unfortunately our collection has failed
in that sense then I will go to sharida
and ask you the same question obviously
not a relative of Dr King yourself but
the words have rung true for a lot of
Americans a lot of black people around
the world not just Americans do you
think that the words have been realized
in today's society
I'll still think that we have uh a lot
more work to do before we could say his
dream was truly realized I mean there
have been some progress but in some
cases as you can see what's happening uh
all over the country as we continue to
lose uh lives senselessly it just seems
like it takes us a step backwards
institutionally do you feel like the
support is there in order to achieve the
the kind of change that is needed and
I'm talking here from government but
also social movements as well
well I think that there are times when
we feel like that uh collectively the uh
social movement is is something that I
definitely believe is in moving in the
right direction there are times when in
general it feels like uh we have the
support uh it sort of wax and wings but
I think um we uh need to whenever we
have those times when it feels like
we're all in sync it's when we have to
really rally together and push the
narrative forward how do it affect like
the Jacksonville shooting how does that
impact you when you hear that it was
racially motivated
well it's like
um unfortunately uh it's happening so
often that it's not something that has
shock value anymore it just seems that
their their overall seems to be this uh
diminished value on the lives of black
and brown people and so when you hear
these incidents happening over and over
again uh there's no shock but what it
does do for me and I think many other
people in the movement is just pushes us
more to say there's still more work for
us to do
Let's cross back over to our video I
think we've managed to re-establish the
connection of you back with us alvida
yes I am can you can you hear me I hope
you can we can we can thank you so much
for making okay thank you so much for
making time it's been a busy few days
for you the 60th anniversary of Dr
King's uh remarks and I'll just ask you
once again where do you feel like he
would be satisfied by some of the
progress that's been made or not at all
at this point
I was a teenager uh in the 1960s I got
married in 69 and one thing that my
uncle would say we must learn to live
together as brothers I'll let as sisters
or Parish together schools and he's in
his own speech he said add righteousness
and Justice together he talked about a
check of insufficient funds so those are
some of the things and some of that is
definitely still here today he also said
we must learn to live together as
brothers and sisters and we are one
blood and one human race that we're not
separate races I think he would want us
to remember that the other point and I
hope it doesn't freeze you have to do
this in every generation every decade
and on every platform because if you
forget your if you don't if you erase
your history you're going to repeat it
again so that's why all this stuff about
burning the history books and locking
all the black kids in the classroom away
from everybody else and telling them
this is happening in Florida as well
there's a school and the black principal
agreed to have the black kids put in
their own separate classroom no you
don't separate you come together act
like human beings and learn human
dignity and to care about each other
that's something Martin Luther King Jr
talked about in that speech cash in that
check for insufficient funds dealing
with racism and uh systemic racism laws
that are written into our laws totally
opposite he said he had a dream that's
rooted in the American dream yeah that's
in that speech so you have to remember
these things but you have to deal with
it yes I agree with the other speakers
there's more to be done and it must be
done in every generation Bonnie in the
studio say really quickly I was a
teenager in the 60s too and and I can
say on one hand absolutely uh things
progress has been slow but in the 1960s
I would not have dreamed of a black man
being tutor my father wouldn't have
imagined that he could not have imagined
that okay he could not have imagined a
black woman as Vice President of the
United States that would not have been
possible for my father my father was
from Mississippi that was impossible and
my friend is the director general of the
Smithsonian and that was something my
father couldn't have imagined so I agree
with everybody every generation we got
to start over we got to let people know
what progress has been made but also
know that there is a long long way to go
a long way to go well Esther sitting in
the studio here representing the British
side of things missing him from you know
we've got three strong black American
voices here talking about they're saying
we've got a long way to go still what
does it mean to you to hear that no I
think they're they're absolutely right
and obviously like I say Britain is not
American and there are different issues
but there are some similarities I mean
obviously when we talk about police
brutality in the US we can't map to that
context onto onto Britain because it's
completely different the social dynamics
and and the inter racial Dynamics are
completely different but they are right
in the sense that there's always work to
be done and there's you know every
generation has to fight for for its
place and fight for the renewal of its
values and I think that's important in
the case of Britain obviously we have
different types of issues uh you know in
discrimination and injustices are
usually linked with social class as
opposed to just race or you know just
ethnicity and so it's a different
struggle but there are underlying
similarities um in the sense that every
generation must continue to reiterate
that the values that keep us to keep us
progressing and keep us together and I
think it's you know it's obviously an
honor to be here
it's an honor to be with you and it's an
honor to hear
um that the Young Voices also know that
every generation has to take Dr King's
words and make them their own not only
take the words but make the words their
own and never forget the ancestors
because of
all the struggle that the ancestors
Let's cross to Alvada for the final
words then on that Aveda if you were to
take any of the words that Dr King spoke
that people should make their own which
would they be
I am a guardian of the King Family
Legacy my daddy Reverend A.D king daddy
king mama and all of them so we are one
blood One race with powerful beautiful
ethnicity let's learn to celebrate it
and stop killing each other that is a
good strong words uh thank you very much
alveda King Sherita as well joining us
thank you also for your insights uh on
this and also here in the studio we've
had Esther and Bonnie chime in on this
it's been great speaking to you all I've
learned a lot uh Bonnie particularly
about your experiences as a teenager
listening to that and how it's inspired
you
you know it wants you to see something
like that and it is important to know
that he didn't he did that on the spot
yeah and that's what was so powerful
about it doing it on the spot that's
what it's all about from the heart thank
you to all of our panelists that's it
from me tonight whatever you're up to
make sure it's unsensitive good night
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
King Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
standal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appear
an abuse of power
when they first got together there were
press stories weighty KTM that would
make her a better princess of wealth
because you're not just marrying the man
the man resonates with Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
let it roll